la pandemia ha modificado la alta
cultura de diversas formas vemos que
algunos diseñadores incluso diseñadores
como usted se han volcado a producir
mascarillas platíquenos más de cómo ha
impactado el coronavirus su industria
mira habla muchas gracias gracias por la
invitación efectivamente en este momento
está comenzando mi participación digital
de videos fashion week y he querido
junto a mis colegas diseñadores de moda
a apoyar a la industria de la moda ya
que el impacto ha sido bastante grande
como decía tuvimos que cambiar todo y
hacer mascarillas yo tengo una fundación
ha donado muchas mascarillas durante 5
meses de la pandemia y bueno comenzamos
a hacer como digo también el fashion
with the new york porque es algo que
tenemos que verlo como cómo seguir
adelante lo no podemos quedarnos
en shock como hemos estado durante este
tiempo y no seguir con el apoyo se nos
ha dado una oportunidad de presentarlo
virtualmente que ha sido un
inconveniente para nosotros porque hemos
tenido que producir todo lo hoy bajo los
patrones de seguridad que nos han dado y
reducir modelos reducir también la
salida de vestuarios el equipo de gente
la montería tasa prácticamente todos
nosotros antes era muy fácil porque
llevamos solo la colección 'la y dior y
la organización se encargaba de
brindarnos todo este servicio pero con
todas las dificultades lo hemos hecho y
seguimos adelante con el apoyo a la
industria de la moda señor hurtado nos
quedan 40 segundos para que cierre esta
emisión pero sí le quiero preguntar que
está presentando esta hora en la semana
de la moda de nueva york que se viene en
esta temporada
mira yo estoy presentando una colección
de alta costura con trajes con telenoche
que se denomina arco iris es una
colección con colores vibrantes trajes
de cóctel noche y también alfombra roja
hago mucho traje de alfombras rojas
bodas
y eso es lo que he presentado en esta
colección yo pienso que uno tiene que
ser fiel a su estilo y seguir haciendo
esto no lo que es una propuesta de
temporada para la siguiente temporada
21 o 22 es la alta costura no tiene
estación de invierno por lo tanto son
trajes de primavera-verano